in this video I want to talk about the
system of Jim Crow segregation which was
common in the United States from about
1877 to approximately 1954 although it
goes a little bit farther than that
now you're probably familiar with some
of the aspects of Jim Crow segregation
from the civil rights movement Jim Crow
segregation involved the loss of voting
rights for African Americans as well as
separate public accommodations and by
public accommodations I mean all sorts
of public spaces in American life so
this might be transportation separate
areas and trains and buses or hotels
bathrooms swimming pools water fountains
so these places in public life where
African Americans were put in the place
of a second-class citizenship where they
could not experience the full range of
movement job benefit protection of the
law or really any of the aspects of
American citizenship that are the
benefits that come with paying taxes and
abiding by the law and during this
period of Jim Crow this kind of
segregation was legal this was not just
in practice but encoded in the law so
where did this system of Jim Crow come
from let's start with the name Jim Crow
a Jim Crow was not the name of a
specific person actually Jim Crow was
the name of a stock character a stock
character is kind of a basic
well-known character and usually a
comedy and we still have stock
characters in comedy today in lots of
different forms of entertainment think
of the absent-minded professor or more
recently the Manic Pixie dream girl now
the the girl who's going to change your
whole life by being so off-the-wall
well Jim Crow was one of these
characters and a form of entertainment
called the minstrel show and the
minstrel show was a very popular kind of
vaudeville type live performance the
minstrel show was actually very popular
in the north of the United States places
like New York City in the 1830s 1840s
kind of this antebellum period before
the Civil War so this character of Jim
Crow was supposed to be kind of the
stupid slave who lived on the plantation
and this character of Jim Crow was
almost always played by a white man
wearing black makeup on his face so it
was not an actual african-american
person but rather a caricature of an
african-american person by a white man
who was part of a minstrel troupe and so
the name Jim Crow became kind of
synonymous with african-americans and
with enslaved people in the early 19th
century the way that say patty became
synonymous with an Irish person so the
term Jim Crow law or the Jim Crow system
means laws that were specifically aimed
at african-americans all right so that's
the origin of the name but where did the
system come from and for that we're
going to have to do a fairly deep dive
into American history and I won't be
able to go into everything here but
let's kind of look at this from the
thousand foot view and get a sense of
the overall pattern of slavery the civil
war and race relations after the Civil
War to see where Jim Crow starts now
I've been daring here and done a
vertical timeline the first thing we
have on here is the end of the Civil War
now before the Civil War in the southern
part
the United States which I have outlined
in red here most of these states had
legal slavery and in these states or the
colonies that preceded them starting
about 1620 they imported African slaves
to be unfree laborers on cash crop
plantations and these might include
tobacco or cotton and that system of
slavery persisted until the balance of
power between the north where slavery
was largely illegal in the south where
slavery was the backbone of the economic
and political system eventually it tore
the country apart into the Civil War on
1863 Abraham Lincoln the President of
the United States issued the
Emancipation Proclamation saying that
all enslaved people in the states which
were currently in rebellion were now
free but it wasn't until the end of the
Civil War that slavery Zend was official
everywhere in the United States and the
end of slavery really posed a problem
for the states of the south now
obviously this was a wonderful thing for
people who had been enslaved now they
had full freedom to move and work and
marry whomever they pleased at least in
theory
but it also meant that the system of
slavery which had dominated the politics
the economics the social system of the
south for more than 200 years was now
over and something had to replace it so
in the immediate period after the Civil
War the question is what are race
relations going to look like in the
south how will whites and blacks relate
to each other without the system of
slavery which has dominated the entire
region for more than 200 years and we'll
get into that in our next video